VALUABLE WINGER CRAIG
SMITH BACK AFTER  VERHA
LEGS.
MARCHAND HITS THE
POST  SQUARE A LOT
SLAMS WEEGAR. THE
BOARDS, VERHAEGHE TO
CHARLIE McAVOY.GHT ON G
KNIGHT RECOVERS.
AS AN
CHANGE, WHAT A END OF T
THE BRUINS HAVE THE
GAP, DID NOT HAVE THE
GAGA
FORBORT'S STICK
SHATTERS IN THE
SEQUED ON IT AND IT
LED TO THE CHANCE
TRICKLES THROUGH THE
KUHLMAN.
HE SENDS NOSEK AHEAD
AROUND, GET THE
SUPPORT  , COMES
ACROSS ,BEEN
EXCELLENT.THE PUCK
THROUGH THE SEAM .
CARLO STEALS FROM
HUBERDEAU, GUDAS, THTH
HAULA GAINS THE LINE
TO DEBRBREAU OFF OF
BERGERON.
COYLE INTERCEPTS AND
GOES THROUGH THE LEGS
AND NITRATE MAKES
THIS A.
>> Andy: PRETTY GOOD
START TO THE THIRD BYBY
ULLMARK TO  REILLY TO U
SPEED UP.  GCE
NIGHT TRAIN.IS
WAY TOO WIDEHAULA
CHARLIE McAVOY  MARCHAN
HIS NORMAL-SIZED.
McAVOY DOESN'T JUJUHIS
SKATES, PASTRNAK IN
,
WE TALK
>> Sophia: FOR DAVID
PAST
WILL START THE
SHOOTOUT.
>> Jack: A RENEWED
JAKE DEBRUSKHIS
THIRD GOAL OF